hey I'm Alicia Keys and today I'm doing
the wired autocomplete interview here we
go
cool Alicia Keys who is Alicia Keys
that's honestly it's a really deep
question I am an artist I am a mother I
am a person who is here to bring amazing
energy I'm a singer songwriter producer
a creator I play piano and I'm here to
take your life and make you feel good
that's who Alicia Keys is bang bang bang
who is Alicia Keys related to I'm kind
of later to anybody although I always
said like the Black Keys or my cousins
but they're not really my cousins but it
would be kind of cool I only have one
brother his name is Cole Cooke
he's fire he's a photographer DP he does
visuals he's amazing creative - who is
Alicia Keys married - I am married to
Kasim Swizz Beatz Dean and we are
complete opposites which is why I think
it works
who was Alicia Keys piano teacher my
first piano teacher her name is Margaret
pine and she actually taught me from
seven or six when I started first
playing piano all the way till about 18
she also taught my oldest son piano to
two point what Alicia Keys what band was
Alicia Keys in my first band that I was
in was just four of my homegirls from my
neighborhood and I don't even think we
got so play so we had a name and then my
second band that I was in was kind of
like one of these projects that are put
together they write people and they
heard I sang and they're like oh maybe
you could be a part of it it didn't work
out with me but eventually they came out
then I think their name was little women
but I was never part of that because I
moved on and they moved on and that
didn't work out for me
and then I had another band that we
would like about 14 I was in and was our
home girls from school and we were
always together at the PL and Harlem and
104th Street singing group Theory's tell
me what you want me to tell me my time
so that was our song we sang like 6,000
times a day trying to like prepare for
anybody that was maybe open a door for
us so nothing really happened with any
other bands I was in but that's okay I'm
grateful for them all there was deep
sisterhood there eventually I you know
found my way to realize and I I wasn't
meant to be in a group what is Alicia
Keys no one about my song right there no
one is just about like the real thing
and that no matter what no one is gonna
get in a way of the real thing they
could talk about you they can think what
they want to think about you but the
truth is when something is real and then
love is real no one can get in away see
what is Alicia Keys New York Alicia Keys
is New York know what period Alicia Keys
is New York boom what is Alicia Keys
unthinkable about all my favorite songs
unthinkable is the first time that I
actually wrote with a Drake which at the
time Drake was like just coming up and
just in the game and we wrote this song
unthinkable I love it so much it's such
a zone but it's really just about are
you ready to do the unthinkable are you
ready to go where you never thought you
could go are you ready to take the leap
take the chance give it a try if you do
the unthinkable would it make us look
crazy or would it be so beautiful either
way if you ask me I'm ready
what is Alicia Keys girl on fire song
about y'all know what that's about
this title what you want about being
damn on fire this and it's about meeting
the stream of this time via lungs and
it's about being able to do karaoke
honestly that's all next slide what's
Alicia Keys doing now like right now
you like sitting here on this zoom
there's a lot of self reflection going
on and who we are in this world during
this quarantine during this pandemic
during this time so I feel like we're
all asking ourselves the same question
which is basically what what is Alicia
Keys what does that mean maybe what is
Alicia Keys a human being beautiful
human being a beautifully powerful human
being what was Alicia Keys childhood
like can you google that because what I
even come up I grew up in Hell's Kitchen
and it is in New York City
born and raised Hell's Kitchen was a
really really dark dark place at the
time that I grew up but it was really
powerful because it also had elements of
Broadway it was right there on 42nd
Street and it had you know where had as
much of the dope fiends and the
prostitutes as Broadway and the bright
light so I think that's a lot of what's
made me who I am that balance and that
difference in that dichotomy between the
darkness and finding a way through it
what is Alicia Keys full name well duh
Lygia keys but if you want to really get
all up into the bidness and the cool a
and everything that my original original
name was Alicia Augello kook that's my
full name at least when I was you know
first born then Alicia Keys became the
performance name and now at least Dean
because I'm married
what is Alicia Keys favorite color
that's not true yeah don't ask that
stuff but my favorite color is purple I
love purple it's just I don't know it
means something to me the royalness of
it the depth of it you know it's so
beautiful and there's so many different
ways that it can be a purple that's me
all day
what is Alicia Keys falling about the
song fallen is one you know the very
first song off of my very first album
called songs in a minor it was about a
relationship that I was in at the time
that was just you know it was sometimes
it was great and then sometimes it was
not great and I just could not figure
out what to do about it
you
and I kept finding myself finding myself
falling back in love with this person
and it was like sometimes I love you
sometimes you drive me crazy and you
know that feeling that we all go through
and we really love somebody but it's
like confusing
that was what falling was about how
Alicia Keys how is Alicia Keys those
granny hoes nervous stressed out losing
my mind
and then after I figured it all out and
got all together really proud and
excited to be there with y'all you know
I hosted it two times and really to
bring a feeling of genuine energy and
camaraderie how was Alicia Keys
discovered well after those 600,000 girl
groups that told you rob that didn't
really work out and didn't go anywhere
one of them had a vocal coach who was
such a beautiful soul named Conrad
Robinson he had a brother who was very
very very much into the music scene and
kind of manage different artists and had
a production company and a whole thing
and so Conrad asked Jeff his name is
Jeff Robinson to come see our group and
when Jeff saw our group he saw something
in me he said you know you should be a
solo artist and I was like no nobody
wants to be a solo artist but that was
the beginning of kind of figuring out
who Alicia Keys was how is Alicia Keys
related to Diana Ross I wish shoes who
don't want to be related to Diana Ross I
mean Tracy is like a sister to me and
she's related to Diana Ross so in a way
I'm Diana Ross's daughter how old is
Alicia Keys son well I have two sons and
one is nine and one is five and I'm
surprised they're not bombarding busting
up in here and all up in my situation
but they're not yet does Alicia Keys
does Alicia Keys act what what planet
you were living on I do act and I love
it so much I've been in some very cool
movies one that you should definitely
watch The Secret Life of Bees which is a
really good one and the other movie you
should watch that I was in it's called
smoking a
that one cult-classic baby does Alicia
Keys play the piano you know the answer
to that hell yeah
does Alicia Keys play the cello that's
good actually I played the cello and
Secret Life of Bees the movie that I was
telling you about
the character that I played played cello
so I had to learn how to play the cello
I had to practice the whole thing it was
hard I'm not even reading that out loud
that's like offensive on to the next one
does Alicia Keys write her own songs yes
I do write my own songs since the
beginning that's been my thing I also
play them and I also produce them is
Alicia Keys the best Oh its Alicia Keys
a mom yeah real good mom too
don't you wish I was your mom coolest
mom ever is Alicia Keys a vegetarian hmm
seriously I don't eat meat but I do eat
fish so you know pescetarian vegetarian
but mostly no dairy so kinda is Alicia
Keys last name really keys I told you
that already
I don't Google myself for I think that's
like really dangerous I'm sure all the
nasty ones were taken out like those
nasty people to ask nasty
[Laughter]